the Las Vegas housing market in the past
year has been hot but does the trend
continue is it a buyer's or seller's
market for the summer we're going to ask
the expert chairman and CEO Bob Hamrick
of Coldwell Banker premier Realty the
sponsors of the segment you're going to
explain it all welcome back Bob hi
Mercedes it's great to be back so great
to talk to you I've been wanting to ask
this what is happening in the market
right now real estate wise it's quite
surprising we were concerned about
interest rates rising and the impact
that that would have on our Market
inventory grew significantly but we are
down to half that inventory now about 4
000 homes for sale
the average sales price has been stuck
at 425 000 but it moved up last month by
1.6 percent to 430. so we're starting to
see a lot of positive momentum in the
marketplace so is this a good time to
sell your home
it's a great time to sell our prices are
down from the high of around 480 so it's
also a great time to buy but the market
is strong and we're seeing multiple
offers on our listings a lot of showings
so it is a good time now if you want
want to sell your home and maybe it it's
not looking as great as it once did you
guys have a really cool program that you
can help the seller out can you tell us
a little bit about that it's called real
vitalize and whether it's a matter of of
fixing up a home or just preparing it
for sale condition is just as important
if not more important than price today
and so being able to ensure that we hit
the home as close to that model home
that people fall in love with the better
and so we have a program that allows our
clients to be able to take advantage of
that at no cost to them up front now
tell us how this works because I love
this this is almost like dressing your
home up in the finest clothes but you
don't have to worry about paying for it
how does it work so we advance the
dollars if it's for painting if it's for
carpeting if it's just for staging we
advance the dollars for doing that and
it typically will cause the home to sell
faster and for a higher price and
ultimately it's paid out of the seller's
proceeds at close of escrow so there's
nothing out of their pocket you're doing
all the legwork what about the
contractors that you use is that the
responsibility of the seller or do you
guys do that that is part of the program
and so we we leverage Angie
um in the process and so the vendors the
great vendors the great quality service
uh it's it's a fabulous program I
think tell us also about this Market
what kind of feedback have you gotten
from people who have used this this
service so we're seeing home selling a
lot faster than they would have we're
selling seeing them selling for twenty
thousand dollars or more in higher sales
price so we we evaluate the property as
it is and also say if you do this it's
likely you'll sell it for more and
they're getting more money absolutely
fantastic Bob thank you so much for
going on and talking to us appreciate it
thank you to Coldwell Banker Premier
Realty for sponsoring this segment you
can scan that QR code on your screen
call
725-234-2277 or visit
realvitalize.com for more information
we'll be right back